There will be people from every tribe,
every tongue, every nation.
There will be people from penile singing the praises
of lamb in their language.
Um, and we, we look forward to that day,
shall I, Alan, uh, and planning Aglo.
And, Hi, I'm Alan, and me
and my wife are planting a church in North Wales.
So my, uh, my first contact with
what I would say true Christianity was, um, was
through an American missionary, um, over in Wales
back in 2012.
Um, so Will Bowden was over from the States.
He was living in Wales as a missionary.
He was the first guy to put a Bible in my hand, um,
and the first person to speak about Jesus
as somebody he knew.
And I didn't have a category for that,
and that was mind blowing.
So that's where my journey began.
So the, um, the first, uh, person from Henderson that I, uh,
that I met was, was Chris Jones.
Um, I met Chris
before I was saved, which was, um, which was great for me.
Um, in that, In our church in Swansea, we didn't have many,
I don't wanna say older Christians, um,
but we'll say more mature Christians.
Um, and so having, uh, mission teams over from Oklahoma,
it wasn't just about evangelism,
but also about showing what mature
Christian life looked like.
And so, um, Chris was kind of Uncle Chris
for a lot of us in that church.
Um, him and his team showing us what it meant to be a,
a mature follower of Christ.
So my wife and I were in a conference down in South Wales
about two and a half years ago.
Um, and although we were seated at different places in,
in the hall, um, during the sermon, uh,
we both felt the Lord speak to us in the same three ways.
Um, the, this quiet voice saying, clean, clean, clean,
which is the area, um, that we're, we're going to move to,
um, it's a peninsula up in North Wales.
Um, we both saw in our, in our mind, a a vision of the,
the mountains of Penea.
And then, um, the Lord spoke to us through,
through the woods of Psalm 121, um,
called Come After Me.
Um, I lift my eyes to the hills from
where does my help come?
And we spent time seeking the Lord in prayer, um,
coming alongside our, our church in Kamar as well, uh,
discerning what the Lord's will was for us.
And, um, became clear that going north
and starting a new work was
what he had in my, uh, in, in store for us.
So the area that we are moving to, um, pen theme
that peninsula up in North Wales, um,
around 10,000 people live in the rural area,
which is the area that we in particular feel called to.
Of those 10,000 people, um,
56% would say that they're Christian.
Um, but realistically, maybe 2%
of them actually attend a place of worship.
And even those places of worship are not ones
where the gospel is being preached.
Um, we would say that there is no healthy church in
that area through the medium of Welsh.
And it is an area where 70% of people speak Welsh
as their first language,
and 77% have some proficiency with the language.
Um, and so the Lord's put it on our heart,
and we think it's, um, a biblical calling to, to make sure
that people hear the gospel in their tongue
and build a relationship with God in their language
and worship him in their language.
We trust that on the last day there will be people from
every tribe, every tongue, every nation.
There will be people from penile singing the praises
of the land in their language.
Um, and we, we look forward to that day.
So the ways that you can be praying for us, um, firstly,
please, please thank the Lord
for he's done in our lives over the last two
and a half years as he's prepared us for this work.
Um, he's been so gracious in bringing a team around us of,
uh, you know, for you guys, it is a small team.
It's six people. Um,
but we're really blessed to have already a, a, a team of,
of people full of zeal for the Lord and his work.
Um, thank the Lord that already
before we're even going, um, in the visits that we've had,
um, some people have given their lives to Christ already,
um, and pray more than anything that we would be faithful to
what he's calling us to do, um,
adding Vete and ene.
Thank you all so much for your prayers.
Um, we are so looking forward to see
what the Lord has in store for us in ine.